hey everyone welcome back to the Spates
water Lab podcast massive shout out to
Spates for bringing you this episode I
do know that you all love a good space
and whether there is the gold medal
lager or the super popular Summit Ultra
maybe the old dark or even the Spate
zero there is no wrong choice when it
comes to choosing your space but right
now it's time to sit back and enjoy this
chat with a true legend also while being
super grateful for our major sponsor
Spates good on you mate
absolute
[Music]
[Applause]
uh what a ladwell the reality of the
sport is that not every gifted young
player gets to have the career that they
hope for in today's guest certainly fits
that category he was an age grade star
he played for the Wellington Lions as a
teenager he also made the Hurricanes
wider Squad when they won the
competition he was on his way to
becoming a household name unfortunately
from then he had a shocking run of
injuries which led him to retire at the
young age of 21. tough one to take for
any young man so I'm looking forward to
hearing how this man handled this
through that tough time he is of course
the great lad himself TJ welcome mate
cheers
I might have to clip that for me
no it's I'm stoked to have you on um
obviously a different rugby journey to
to many of my guests but like I said
like not everyone can reach the ultimate
dream and obviously looking forward to
hearing how you handled it and you got
through
um your tough journey to to be where you
are now obviously killing it with the
RPA yeah bro no um I listened to the
podcast with Tim Bateman a couple months
ago bro and I thought there's a lot of
power in the message that he was giving
um and I think it's a reality for not
just people who kind of went up through
that high performance area but even
people who didn't necessarily quite make
it to that level um I think there's a
lot of lessons and similarities between
it and so
um catching up with you a couple weeks
ago and then seeing them wanting to
seeing the the appetite I suppose for
people who don't want to learn more
about their Journey or um you know
lessons that people and I think there's
heaps of power in there so Keane has a
rip and do it bro mate there's it's a
massive space like there's no doubt and
the message that I had from that Tim
Bateman one
um it's sort of blown me away with how
many people have struggled post footy
and that's a lot of the guys who've got
to the end of their career so they've
had an opportunity to get there they
knew it was coming but for you obviously
to be taken away from you so young must
be incredibly hard for you yeah because
like you're saying some some people they
get to go through their Journey on their
own terms however they want some people
overnight it works like that mine was a
bit bit of a slow burn
um in their way so it was pretty yeah
pretty interesting I mean kind of went
through
as I say four years I was in the
professional environment fully
unprofessional after leaving high school
and then of those four years um it was
six months scattered around it where I
could physically play the game of rugby
sure so scattered in between all those
moments there was a lot of adversity and
lessons that I kind of picked up on and
then probably didn't even really
um absorb or fully comprehend until a
few years out of the environment yeah so
I think
their first year
um jumping in straight out of high
school I'd come off of a real real
successful real happy kind of um
uh proud year going leaving High School
um I just signed with Wellington lines
at the beginning of the year
um at the beginning of year 13 I uh it
just kind of pivoted away from rugby
league I was going to go over and do the
um the 20s of Melbourne storm
environment oh true
um pivoted around to rugby just because
there was the infrastructure was there
I'd learned a lot more through the camps
so I thought it'd be a easier um
Pathway to go through and in my hometown
as well uh yeah jumped into uh
the the schools environment
um we won my local high school we won um
our first ever Wellington Camp went
through made the Nationals Finals
um I was water with the secondary
schools uh campaign off the back of that
we went into Condors uh seven
Internationals and I kind of um
uh yeah we made the national final again
and then uh I was had the honor of
making that team again and so coming off
the back of that year I think everything
was really kind of prime and ready and I
felt that I was about to arrive in a way
um I felt that I'd I just gained a lot
of confidence it was something I
believed in my entire life growing up
knowing that that was the journey I
wanted to embark on and those were the
the places I wanted to arrive on on the
way towards eventually wanting to become
an all black and a great one at that and
so
um those realities a uh in a way kind of
affirmed to me what I what I always
believed it and then so going into that
first year out of high school I was real
real Keen to rip into things
um very first uh physical game after
leaving High School uh tore my ACL true
um I was playing sevenscon just went for
a cut and then just tried to step
someone a bit too much
um ripped yeah ripped it apart I had
never experienced the major injury
before I think the longest during high
school was like a three four week
hamstring and then so I didn't even know
how to um explain what had happened I
basically told the the doctors that I
felt weightless between my knee and my
the rest of my body
um and it felt like it went around
felt like it ripped and then in a way
you went back
um so I didn't really know how to to
communicate that yeah as well as I was
in a bit of a denial thinking like no
this wasn't my fault yeah I didn't do
this is someone else's you know I've
worked way too hard for this so there's
no way that something wild happened to
my legs straight out straight out
um and then it got misdiagnosed because
I think there's a lot of me to blame and
the way I communicated it I mean it
doesn't sound like all the you know like
a torn ACL
um got misdiagnosed that as a um
dislocated patella oh yeah I worked
eight to twelve weeks on rehab that came
back
um and then inevitably a win again
um felt the niggles again
um and then after about two or three
times of that I think I think
something's up this isn't two or three
times of of the experience of having
torn my ACL oh wow so I got to around
Midway through the year before it kind
of got diagnosed that I went and got the
scans and it was a tornacio
[Music]
um
and then in a weird way I was excited
when I found out because I finally got
some closure on what was going on but I
also was like oh yeah you know you've
been telling yourself your whole life
this is what you want this is you know
one one setback that's come on what are
you gonna do about it and and I got
excited at the thought of that
um because you know I I was willing to
work as hard as anyone and you know and
be on the physical side of it as well
and so I kind of took that challenge
with both hands and ripped into it
fortunately through that um during that
time frame I got picked up by the
Hurricanes as well for that wider
training going into The Following season
I got the got the rehab done and
um kind of got to March the following
year and I was ready to play again so
um one thing that I always kind of took
pride in off the back of that was the
Hurricanes was there at the time
um in my return to play he said it was
the best ACL rehab he'd ever seen and
this one is in in his career there was
again a lot of confirmation for me that
I'm doing something right um
and then the second game back I didn't
even made it to playing 40 minutes you
know you've got to go through the return
to play yeah
um yeah tour it again and so that that
shattered me I just remember
um
coming getting carried off on the uh the
club rugby game and I'm just an absolute
tears just to get down uh yellow
inconsolable
um yeah kind of ripped me apart because
I I knew the sensation now I knew what
had happened I knew exactly you know
what I'd gone through and
it kind of got confirmed a few weeks
later after the scan um
but position I was in at the time going
into a under 20's campaign that coming
up wanting to really you know not miss
my second miter 10 season I think that's
what it's called at the time
um with the Wellington lions and just a
whole lot of rugby to want to play off
the back of I think it was probably 18
months now
where I hadn't really got to play much
rugby
um tried to push through there are some
some stories of athletes who had had a
torn ACL and rehabbed around it um you
know built up the quad the hammies
everything around it and they were able
to play through and so
being quite young and eager to want to
um you know make a name for myself in
the environment
um I just jumped into it and
basically same stuff happened throughout
the year luckily I go to nz20's campaign
out of it
um unfortunately it's the worst at the
time yeah the result that we got but um
you know it had an incredible experience
with some of the guys
um in that environment but yeah had
about two more episodes of that
happening
um to me throughout the year where and
he buckled again and basically it would
start from square one with the eight
week rehab all right yeah and then uh I
eventually got to a position in between
all the niggles to play for um the lions
come off the bench for a debut done
against otago I think it was
um again nowhere near my fittest I'm
trying to
you know fight my way through knowing I
didn't have a good knee uh
wind I was pretty dusty actually in that
case
the following game um
came off the bench so I covered nine for
their first game and then the following
game I got to cover 10. oh yeah and that
was that's quite fun because that was my
preferred position I got to be out in
the field a bit more
um played alright got a bit more
confidence Off the Bench from that game
and then that next week I got to go into
up up north of the counties game
um so this was my first time throughout
that whole
um kind of experience where I was
starting to string together games as a
professional not struggling to get into
the Academy games or Club games just to
get minutes under my belt yeah how was
your knee feeling at this point no it
was buggered Brooke oh it it tested
strong but mentally I didn't trust it at
all so I I there were just clips of
training throughout the weeks where
someone would rush me on one side and
I'd just Buckle I'd just go down because
I was scared oh yeah so I'm great and so
I think those
there's some pretty clear tests okay
something's pulling all right bro
um so we went into that County's game
and I came off the bench I was a real
tight game uh it's probably like 20 30
to go I got a kick racy and went to go
to a bit of a um
counter attack uh stepped off it and I
think Sean Trevi was next to me at the
side at the time and he says he just
hurt it just he just heard everything oh
um and so the whole thing just kind of
went apart
um and then I think at that point it was
like the you can't hold it together at
this point you need to go under the
knife again and so yeah through that
journey and I think from that moment it
was probably where the mental battle
kind of came in with everything because
I'd been holding it together in a way
not in the healthiest way either but
I've been holding it together for for so
long that this was kind of the thread
that unraveled things that I'd been
trying to
conceal or was neglecting in my own life
um and yeah from there kind of
it was 22 months until I played my next
game
um just on top of injuries again so I
was kind of yeah through that through
that um that four year period it was
a lot of a lot of injuries a lot of
long-term Energy Group yeah in the gym
by myself and
tiny hints or slivers of getting to
experience what I really truly wanted
yeah just couldn't even get onto the
field to
try and you know play for a jersey yeah
how come you didn't get that knee
surgery like that second knee surgery
earlier even though you obviously felt
like it was it wasn't right like
mentally you weren't trusting it how
come you didn't decide to get the
surgery on earlier before it did go yeah
I think I alluded early like there were
examples of people who had done that and
I think being quite young and confident
I was like I will be one of those people
it was that aspect of it I think I was
in denial in a way I didn't want to face
it again I didn't want to pull myself
back through that again kind of knowing
that
this one's gonna hurt a lot more not
physically but it just mentally to me
um
and I think the the weight of
expectations as well that I'd put on
myself and that I I told myself that
others were putting on me knowing that
um you know you were this kid who came
into the environment
um got a super contract off of not
really playing that year off of
um
first I've seen highlights in a way yeah
um and coupled with wanting to try and
feel like I fit in in a way I've had the
sense of imposter syndrome this whole
time I was in the environment because
and it had nothing to do with my
environment but it was it was the story
I was telling myself
because I couldn't you know when you're
in the high performance environment you
can always back up on how you play and
how you perform I didn't I never had
that pillow to rely on
um even though I still believed that I I
could build it up and I could I could
back it up eventually one day or maybe I
was delusional you know but
um I think not not having that pillar
made me wants to drive towards some
other way to prove myself in a way yeah
and then that final part as well was
being the coach's son of the Wellington
Lions as well yeah I think that was
something that I was wanting to prove
and also wanting to make the most of to
know how long my dad wanted to coach
there what what was going to happen so I
really wanted to get in so there's a lot
that went into well now looking back is
a very clear decision yeah so obviously
you're dead over uh um Samoan
International Legend how much pressure
was there following his sort of
footsteps from from a young age you
spoke about having a real drive to
become an all black even a great one at
a young age where did that sort of come
from was that was that from your old man
or where did that come from yeah I
suppose the drive it was never like
I don't think it was ever a moment in my
life where my dad told me he wanted me
to pursue this yeah it was always very
internally driven in my environment I
was definitely surrounded by a lot of
great athletes growing up so you talk
about that whole um
you know people can't be what they can't
see I was surrounded by it constantly
and I saw great all blacks and I saw a
great International Rugby players and
NRL Stars growing up out of wainuiomata
as well you know um
that's a very clear pathway that um that
I was
shown
um or that I was kind of around and so I
just wanted it
um that coupled with the fact that I
loved playing loved the game you know
some of my earliest memories running up
and down my Nan's hallway uh just
playing rugby by myself with a ball
getting told off or making all this
noise you know so I never felt like he
ever or he or anyone in my family ever
told me this is what we expect of you
but it was the stories again that I was
telling myself that I expect this of
myself but I also want it so it kind of
came into twined in a way and as I began
to see results I think that was that
expectation that slowly started to come
in as well yeah when were those results
was that from a real young age where
yeah really talented as even a
five-year-old I wasn't really I was just
really Keen just real competitive and
always like looking for the edge yeah so
even from like a young age I was always
fully immersed in that I was I was
watching the games I was watching
highlights of Dan Carlo video yeah
um not just because I liked watching I
was like oh how could I do this how
could I bring this in and so
yeah and there are aspects of it
um
and then Your Big Break was you've
spoken about already about Scott's
college and it's where you really I
guess it was it noticed by everyone in
New Zealand that you had a stack team
that year
um Jensen twins
um Connor got him Bear Ship Alex feder I
remember coming to watch one of your
games at school
um one year and man you guys were pretty
talented group yeah you're looking back
now you can see the pathways that people
went on you're like oh heck yeah it was
a stack team but at the time none of us
had
um you know kind of made a name for
ourselves or made made reps teams or
being the superstars of those reps teams
so
um we didn't really understand what we
had in front of us at the time I think
yeah and then on top of that you know
being coached by my dad as well I think
he kind of put all the infrastructure
and the game plans and everything around
us that when we started to believe it
and we saw it then things kind of bought
from there yeah and were you playing
League at the time at the same time yep
yeah it was a real common thing for
heaps of people
um
know oh you know a lot of kids who are
kind of in and around the league
environments as well is that you'd grow
up playing rugby union on the sad days
and then league on Sundays and then on
Tuesday Thursday was the rugby trainings
Monday Wednesday was the league
trainings and it was just a real nice
way to stay around and just jam with all
your friends really and how close you
mentioned the Melbourne storm how hard
was that decision for you to stay in
Wellington or was the temptation to go
over there and be part of that Melbourne
storm under 20s
um that was actually an easy decision in
the end only because like I was saying
before I wasn't fully immersed in League
probably from the age of 14 onwards and
even though I was a league kid through
and through growing up I'd think I'd I
didn't even play start playing rugby
until I was about 10 so it was rugby
league that I loved oh yeah that was
where I learned to play but I just I
learned so much around how to play the
game of Rugby Union
um and I've been so immersed in those
environments growing up even though I
was going to um
the the storm camps every summer those
two weeks were the only Snippets of real
you know competitive rugby league I was
around so that compared to a full year
of all these environments it was quite
easy by the time I got to the age of 17.
do you ever think what if or whatever
does your mind ever go down that road
yeah yeah 100 not even just around rugby
league there's so many what-ifs stuff in
sports but um yeah I'm completely at
peace with what happened so yeah I don't
think it's something I dwell on it's
it's more like a fun and fun thing to
think about because I love watching the
Melbourne storm now oh yeah you just
think right that should be me yeah I
just appreciate what those guys
scared me bro
their trainings are crazy you like to
stay the hardest thing I'd ever been
around oh wow oh that's right so it's um
I have a deeper appreciation rather than
any resentment or anything yeah sure I
suppose you weren't able to do too many
preseasons anyway
I was King of the Road really in the
preseason
it's interesting how you mentioned um
The Imposter syndrome especially like
going into the Hurricane's environment
um like you said sign pretty much On
Schoolboy highlights not being able to
train or play or prove yourself must
have been incredibly hard for you
mentally to feel like you belonged yeah
yeah one thousand percent I think I
always kind of struggled with that sense
of belonging in the in all the high
performance environments I was in after
school
um purely because my whole life I'd kind
of hung my hat on
being able to rely on proving myself
through performance so when that was no
longer there and I was so accustomed to
having the status of just falling back
on that
um it's kind of actually start to
consider like where where does my value
derive from um and that was a real
you know long journey I really struggled
in in the environments because I never
felt like I found my place um and again
nothing to do with the environments it
was all the stories I was telling myself
internally
think there's a saying that I really I
really began to draw on as I left the
environments was around like if you seek
nourishment from external validation
you'll be um you'll be hungry forever oh
and that was something when I looked
back it was clearly something I was
looking for um
because I was accustomed to it and then
I had never really sat with myself and
and figured out what am I about what I
really enjoy
away from the game of sports and so as I
began to navigate that journey in the
few years where I was injured
I I can see so clearly now me doing
things and being someone that I wasn't
in a way to try and fit in putting a
mask on to console in a way and to try
and force that belonging yeah rather
than
intrinsically figuring out what's
important to me who's important to me
why it's important yeah and then
naturally the people around me will
align with them that's something that
yeah again not until I kind of decided
to to step remove myself from those
environments was I able to kind of see
clearly and get that full view
um yeah quote example like what sort of
things were you doing that you felt like
you you were just doing to fit in like
up like naturally I'm a reserved and
introverted person yeah when I look back
at so many of my memories around the
sporting environment I was trying to be
a voice I was trying to be the Joker I
was trying to
because I was just trying again and seek
that sense of belonging and acceptance
from people yeah um so that was an
example and an extension of that was
then going out and partying yeah um
which to me now so clearly is like it's
I'd much rather just have a movie night
with your fiance or with my with my
sister and my nieces and nephews yeah
I'm like that yeah yeah probably more
just around that that side of things
just trying to be someone I wasn't yeah
mate it's interesting and you spoke
about like that second knee surgery how
hard that was for your mentally like
what what's the toughest challenges
there for you
um
yeah it was purely the mental stuff that
because the the physical stuff was
things I'd been through again there were
tiny like tiny differences that second
time around
um and took longer but it was for me it
was mentally
um probably in that final year high
school I started to feel random bouts of
anxiety oh yeah I'm like just the weight
of the world on me and then because it
was the weight that I'd put there on
myself
um and then I never really explored that
I never asked myself why am I doing that
why am I feeling that I just I just let
it be what is that feeling
for me it's um in my experience when it
came with that stuff around anxiety was
I just feel like I've got so much to do
in such a little time oh yeah um I feel
like it's out of my control
I feel I felt um you know physically
sweaty
um
heart rate can't think clearly
um and then off the back of that I'd
want to kind of
uh separate myself from others and also
feel shame in a way of that but so I
first felt elements of that in high
school as I was going through but I
never did anything about it
um and then
little parts of that kind of came out
during those first few years especially
as I was trying to find that comfort in
their belonging of wanting to be around
someone or something or a group um that
I felt accepted me and then that that um
second surgery it really kind of brought
out all the things that were under the
surface that I've been holding in
um I had to get that surgery on my 20th
birthday I think um going on the morning
and that that really broke me couldn't
really be around my family and I wasn't
really doing something that you know
shattered me and then over that year I
yeah just started to kind of go into a
bit of a
um and I I removed myself from the
supportive environments and I took
myself to the environments where I
thought would help me grab quick easy
senses of belonging on on the surface
it looked like me hanging out with
people or hang around in temporary
groups that weren't really what I was
about you know
um coping in different ways different
substances drinking going out anxiety
shooting up now coming at in more more
frequently and for longer me me just
really wallowing in a way and that was
it got to a point where I knew it was it
was actually really clear to someone in
the environment that I was struggling uh
that person reached out to me and
offered support and helped me kind of
talk about it and then find Pathways
that were available or resources that
are available to me so I went to therapy
through that time because I was really
struggling with that sense of you know
what's my purpose now that I can't rely
on this pillar I built my whole life
around and that really that really
helped me to begin to see the signs of
why of when I was beginning to to spiral
um I was able to kind of build a game
plan around that
um learning more about myself during
that process as well
and
as I kind of navigated through the highs
and the lows in that year it got to the
following preseason and in the lead up
to I flew over to Japan where my dad was
now coaching uh my mum my little sister
were there I spent the off season with
them and just trained the house down
from there filling my cup being around
my family the whole time
and then kind of came back off the back
of coming back to New Zealand off the
back of that had all these kind of
processes in place or
um I'd really built out my understanding
of myself and kind of was ready to rip
into that pre-season because I was
getting close to being able to play
and then yeah I got to do the stuff to
Peak for the first time oh in three
years yeah
but I took a lot of um sense of pride in
it because as a first one of the first
areas I got to compete with everyone and
there was something I missed a lot being
able to fully compete
um I got I finished with the best time
in my position and so that's something
that meant a lot to me at the time
um I got an award for the preseason for
um best skills which at the time when
you're in the environment it's not
really that big a deal at all but it
meant so much to me at the time yeah
because again it was one of the first
moments where I felt like I could
compare and compete so how did you get
that hurricanes contract with all these
injuries I so this did you say year
three in the hurricane so after that
because I signed the first year 2015
going into 2016 for a one year wider
yeah
um and then I think just through the
moments of them seeing how hard I was
working but also seeing the moments when
I was playing and what I was able to get
myself back to for the NZ 20s campaign
oh yeah you got to sign from there two
years from here oh that's cool and then
it was out basically
yeah so you did yourself to Peak yeah
um yeah got the got the that sense of
Pride over kind of being able to compete
again I came back and then the first
time I was close to being able to be
named for something for the canes Woody
told me that I was going to be able to
play at the tens what was it the
Brisbane oh yeah Brisbane teams yeah
yeah
um would be able to play in the
following preseason and then I think
there was one more after that and
depending on performances you go in
there and you could be on the birds of
South Africa yeah and that was the first
time I was like I actually see a light
now yeah it was the end of this tunnel
and so
you know I've things felt great
everything was kind of firing on all
cylinders I thought in a way
um and then I I tweaked my hamstring
kind of going into that Brisbane tens
week and they're really
they're really hurt for a bit but it was
only like a three or four week and there
was like a blink of an item point
um and then working back through that
return to play completely tore my
hamstring and from there they put me out
from like I think it was eight to twelve
weeks and then this this one this moment
here was like the thing that just kind
of
just shattered everything for me
um and the Lights Went Out basically was
in I was doing return to play again
um
we're doing a bit of a
um one-on-one drill so just doing a bit
of agility and it's I got possible you
had to have a go against the defender I
turned the corner it's up against um
Chase Theater who's close friend of mine
as well
um
I just remember at vividly I just went
to kind of goose stepping away my
hamstring went and I went to buckle I
went to support myself and then my knee
went and I told him in the same time the
other leg so I had to stand up and I
just couldn't stand and I was confused
as and then that year the lights I don't
really remember much of that you the
kind of the lights just went out where
the fire like just went out just not in
regards to sport just in general that
really that really hurts so I honestly
can't tell you what how we went as a
team that year in that Keynes
environment
um
I remember Snippets of kind of what went
on but I was in a deep deep hole um
yeah I remember moments something that
really cools out to me was um
Dan Coles came around one I think it was
straight after actually when he heard it
happened and came to console me but as
in as people would know who've been in
those spaces
when that when that switch is turned
sometimes even though the help's there
you're not willing to take it and I was
so far gone at that point so I yeah the
next months are a blur really
um
did all the rehab eventually got back to
playing
um for the first time in those 22 months
but uh
was that 22 months yeah from the second
ACL surgeon wow yeah forced myself to
play I couldn't Sprint I'd refuse to
Sprint
um both I think physically still but
mentally I just wouldn't put myself
there um went into the lions campaign
and I just knew I just couldn't
um couldn't run physically mentally it
was in a horrible place and then
contractually I was coming off contract
and the passion wasn't there anymore it
was kind of at a point where I felt that
everything was taking away rather than
giving at this point
um not at any fault to the game or
anything or the people in the
environment it was
I had just gotten so wrapped up in this
hole where I couldn't see the joy
anymore and
um so I think a few weeks into the lines
campaign I I asked them to release me on
my contract
um and then yeah released me from there
and I the plan was I was going to step
away and work on myself mentally
physically rebuild myself again and then
jump back into it but the way it ended
up turning out was that you know all
that stuff worked out great I um went
through such a healing Journey but um
physically as I still had I had two more
surgeries I'd still get done just from
um ongoing niggles
as I was whenever I tried to rebuild
myself again to want to play I'd come
across adversity again and then the
desire was no longer there where I was
willing to continue to push so I'd get
Keen
I get a nickel and then I kind of lose
the excitement of it again yeah and that
kind of went on for another two years
um and then just because all the other
things I'd been exploring in my life I
began to find excitement in other areas
and then kind of as rugby went down and
tried to go back up and would go back
down yeah other areas of my life just
grew
um and kind of just took it from there
and then yeah it's been however hello
ghosts mate that is a brutal
brutal injury toe yeah someone's so
young so you were like 21 or 21 when
you're retired yeah you know because I
didn't think of it you never really yeah
yeah you never really retired we still
haven't really you might be back you
might might get that burning desire
again so how old are you now 26 Now 26
yeah see he's still so young so
right that's crazy what did you miss
most about the game like when you did
retire or were you just like not even
interested in it anymore how do you feel
about the game once you had sort of
moved away from it yeah but I'd lost
complete interest in the game didn't
care to watch anything one for the first
few years or yeah first couple years it
was more out of pain yeah not caring to
watch it but then as I kind of went
through my own journey and healed and
could kind of look at it without that
emotion and surrounded by it I just
found out I wasn't actually as
interested anymore but in terms of what
I missed the number one thing I miss and
because this is the only yeah the only
thing I miss really is being able to go
out and jam on a whim any point go play
a game of flag go play touch you know
race race my mates if we're arguing when
we're drinking yeah so you can't do it
what you can do nothing there I can
build towards it but I just
there's still so much trauma around some
of the areas where I'm not willing to
push myself that much anymore yeah and
in the sense of lag and touch and stuff
there's still so many similarities in
cutting and sprinting yeah that it takes
me a lot to get just there yeah so I
just don't have as much energy to get
there and that that was something I
really struggled with leaving the
environment then was
was continuing to take care of myself
physically growing up the entire time
and being in that environment it was
always geared to being the best player
um I was never someone who loved my PB
numbers or was trying to to win the surf
to Peak I was trying to be the best
player and through doing that I was
going to tick off the boxes that you
gave me yeah and I'd be disciplined
about it and I'd I'd commit to it but
when that fire was no longer there or
their end goal is no longer there I
really struggled with my relationship
with the physical side because it was
always geared towards one thing and so
going to the gym seemed pointless like
to me because I was like but I'm not
trying to play yeah never mind just
General Health
so that that had been it's something I'm
still kind of navigating it's successful
the last six months or so but checking
in a year or so I don't want to speak
too soon I'm get I'm working my way
through it yeah that's something I
really found hard after leaving mate I
was the same like there's that's
probably the biggest thing for me is
trying to find time to do physical
exercise something that you know you're
forced to do throughout your career not
force but it's part of your program it
is every third day or second day you're
doing weights or conditioning or
whatever it is so to have the option to
do that or not always choosing not at
the moment and then on the other side of
that was my relationship with food
because again the discipline side was
geared towards oh take care of my skin
is everything so that I can be the best
athlete yeah but then when that was no
longer there I felt like
all these kind of limitations around
what I could eat how much I could eat it
was gone and so as I went away from that
I went away towards that and then as
well as like you know going out and
drinking and partying more so yeah I
just I didn't really know how to
how to navigate and limit myself because
I didn't feel like I
had a physical goal anymore yeah mate
you're in good shape considering no
exercise and eating all sorts no no the
yeah the last six months I've definitely
been on a journey look at that stuff out
but it's been tough yeah back and forth
that's great and then you mentioned when
the rugby came down the other side of
your life came up so so what was that
what did that look like yeah so
um
you know the blessing through all of the
injuries was that I had the time to do
all my study throughout and so when I
decided to leave that environment I had
one four years worth of uni papers left
I might agree
um and so in that following year I went
back to UNI studied that immersed myself
more around the environment and the
people that were there the people that
I'd never really given time to because I
was like I'm here just to do you know
ticker box yeah yeah I'm not I'm not
here yeah I'm not entirely here and so I
got to discover more around that
environment I've you know made friends
with people that I wouldn't typically
spend more time around because I was
always in and out during the bare
minimum to get there
um
of the back of there
um went to some you know uni event
nights with one of my mates who dragged
me along and then heard about this call
as internship opportunity through
organization called tip tour so it helps
um uplift representation of Maori
Pacifica in the corporate sector and I
was like oh this seems so cool and I was
like oh and I'm finishing my uni degree
scene I should probably look into this
stuff now and so I went along to it and
then just through just chasing that
Curiosity and being more interested in
things now
um or letting myself be more interested
in things
um found myself going through there and
picking up an internship
um in in the summer in that summer
uh got matched with a place called
Deloitte who at the time I didn't really
know anything about yeah uh started a
strategy Consulting internship and
aligned with my degree in what I talked
about in my internship interview what I
enjoyed I talked about back in the
sports environment I loved strategy I
loved
I loved fixating around a plan that's
going to help us
um succeed on whatever that version
success meant to us
um and being able to adapt to changing
pictures you know stuff like that and
those just happen to align with um you
know what they were looking for at the
time so I picked up that and then went
into another completely different
environment of people who I never would
have been immersed around during or
would have wouldn't have let myself
immerse myself around them yeah
um and then just made such good friends
with so many different characters you
know completely old way older than me
younger than me
um learned to be at peace with myself as
well through this journey of wanting to
to heal as well alongside all of that
and then yeah just through that I just
kept chasing that Curiosity and finding
myself in these cool environments off
the back of that internship I um
I did some some work out of my local
community
um was being able to support the the ACT
some of the at-risk students at the
local high school I went back to
Deloitte started on the grad program in
the actual strategy Consulting Group
um
yeah so like went on a bit of a journey
on all these different areas
um even like just started to take more
awareness around what I would do with my
spare time find myself watching YouTube
videos of you know how they made certain
movies or what it meant by that or
um find myself wanting to clip together
videos take film photos of my family
capture those moments and learning how
to pick up on their skills yeah and just
by being more aware of that I was you
know I was able to understand we're like
oh I actually have hobbies and interests
yeah that was something I really
struggled to answer or hated people
would ask me when I was in the
environment the player profile what's
your hobbies
but like now I understood more around
why I do what I do yeah or I take more
awareness around that and so
through that journal just yeah I found
so many different
um interests yeah and you mentioned your
healing process throughout all this time
what does that look like what is what
does the healing process look like
um so
staying on with therapy
um after a bit of time of kind of going
probably backwards after I initially
left because I was I felt like just I'd
open myself up to this world and was
like what is going on
um and then coped with it in my own
unhealthy ways at the time I then went
back to regular therapy to talk about
things and
um to learn to unravel why maybe I'd
arrive so much early from this or from
there or why it meant so much when
someone said passing comment about
something and why I would hold up for
for weeks and then looking for the
trends of what would I usually do after
that and just kind of watching that
cycle
um of you know bad habits just
turn into a feedback loop so yeah
um I mean along that Journey like went
to a therapy class once with my mum not
class sorry a therapy session with my
mum because I felt it so hard to talk to
my loved ones about what I was going
through because I didn't want to burden
them with the weight of what I thought
were my problems right
um you know in reality as I went through
that and we you know went through this
this journey together
I was able to to see it was it was
actually something that helped them get
into the mind of what was going on with
me and I didn't have to hold shame over
it regardless of what I was thinking
because it was all it was all meaning
that I'd attached to it so you know
doing doing things like that
um being very over communicative with
how much I loved my friends and family
yeah um because they began to show that
gratitude and appreciation for what was
going around so it
um yeah and I think just sitting with
myself a lot
um
during uni
you know just I
I have because I still had Shame about
like last year I was here now this is
what I'm doing yeah no one knows who I
am all this stuff I've relied on I began
to sit with my thoughts and off the back
of what I was learning in different
environments
uh whether it be my personal
relationships or my
um
relationship with my my therapist I was
able to begin to unravel with myself as
well um and over time just picked up
more tools listened to more people you
know read more books around around kind
of that journey and over over a time it
began to make more sense to me I think
something I really an image I always
love when they talk about therapy is
like
if you look at a knotted piece of string
that's just kind of your mind before
going into therapy afterwards all it is
is just just very clearly unraveled and
that's how you know I think that
sentiment really captures how I feel
through that process is that it just
helps me understand why this equals this
and over time you become more you can
help yourself become more self-aware and
continue to learn more and unravel um
and off the back of that you can be more
intentional and conscious with the
decisions you make on the back of that
and if it does or doesn't align with who
you want to be and what's important to
you
all right it's so cool I love that and
you mentioned around
um sort of the downhill spiral what does
that look like you mentioned drugs
alcohol what did it look like for you
yeah just more hardened versions of
those those things that are saying that
I experienced during the sports
environment I just again I felt like I
had no limit on this stuff now yeah so I
just you know would would go out would
party all the time would socialize all
the time despite the fact it took so
much energy away from me yeah
um muck around with drugs
um temporary relationships with
different people it's just there's
things that didn't align with who I am
and what's actually important to me but
in a way I didn't know yeah it was
important to me as well so I was just I
was lost so I just found tried to find
Solace or quick hits of of Love or
affection or connection from other areas
and you you mentioned your mate who
noticed that helped you what did he say
because you see it all the time with
people who you know aren't quite
dealing with something very well how did
he help you how did he convince you to
go to therapy or get you back on the
straight
so he told me I looked like [__] one day
straight up as it and then
you could kind of see that I was hurting
and then but him opening up
that that kind of Channel where I could
tell a kid in his own funny way
um that was all I needed I just needed
someone to ask how things were going
from a different environment and then I
just I opened up and then was able to
figure out what it was that um
yeah what I could begin to do to help
myself
um
that's cool and then your role now I
want to speak to me about what you're
doing now you work for New Zealand Rugby
Players Association what does that look
like yeah so the role I'm doing at the
moment um it's officially called The
Learning development project manager so
they they've created this this awesome
as online platform
um and app uh called called the Hub
um and so the whole premise around it is
to create short uh interactive engaging
modules and courses that provide all the
professional rugby athletes in New
Zealand uh
key information resources contacts
for key topics in the personal
development program and so it's all
about the personal development program
you'd know and those who are in the
rugby environment would know as um you
get about I think it was a half a day a
week in your contract dedicated towards
personal development and that that in
itself is freaking awesome like the fact
that that is there to protect you know
the welfare of athletes and help them
prepare themselves for either Life For
Life Beyond footy
um
so you know in and around areas of your
well-being your finances
um your Career Education Pathways your
skills your opportunities that you want
to explore off the back of that
um it's all many courses and modules
that you can as an athlete go towards
yourself or work with your personal
development manager to to complete and
work through and explore if you know if
this is a topic that you know you're
really interested in you can learn more
about it but in the meantime here are
some very short
um courses and straight to the point
answers that are going to help you and
it kind of comes into fruition through
like uh mini videos
um
interviewing multiple players
um talking about their lived experience
with their topic interviewing subject
matter experts on this topic to give you
the cold and hard facts around it
um
yeah so it's been a real exciting role
real awesome place to hop into the
environment is awesome
um organizations that are learning so
much from everyone in that environment
um but I think the way I found myself
there
kind of extends what I was talking about
with those different areas of Interest I
had after leaving was that I was I was
really enjoying myself and have had a
really great job at um at the Lloyd as a
strategy consultant but I was kind of
getting to a point where I could either
decide to
work my way up the line again and you
know work for a certain promotion maybe
or
I could kind of pivot off of that and
look for something that has a bit more
meaning to me
um I loved aspects of the work we did
yeah but I couldn't see myself long term
being able to work across all those
different you know Banking and insurance
sector pieces of work that would come
across it
um but when I thought of the the
prospect of
doing something in and around Sports
um
that 100 kind of aligned with me I I
fully believe in the power that Sports
has to like bring together communities
to to teach you valuable life lessons
um to yeah I think it's a really great
force for Change and it was something
that I was raised around my entire life
and it's another way I can kind of
re-look and still take value from all
those aspects of growing up that I
thought was only meant to be a player
yeah
so jumping into this space I just find I
have endless energy around it because I
truly believe in in the power of it so
you see yourself doing this long term or
what's the next sort of five ten years
look for yeah yeah 100 see myself being
able to play around in the sports
industry um long term uh next five ten
years it's just continuing to get around
all the leaders in and around all the
shot callers all
the influential people in the
environments I want to get around
um
something that a lesson I was saying I
really took with me when I went into
Deloitte was if you're the smartest in
the room you're in the wrong room oh man
it's like you're saying
it's really the great
so that that
um
that message and it really helped me see
the power of learning from anyone
regardless of what situation I'm in but
now I'm just being a bit more
intentional knowing that I know I'm
going to be here long term
um who around here can I continue to
learn from and put me in a position that
aligns with what I've talked about with
my purpose of what one of my purposes
with um you know using the power sports
uh Drive Social educational Health
outcomes for people I'm surprised you've
stayed in this room with me for so long
yeah you're in the wrong room
too smart for me
but what a journey anyway we've gone to
our Instagram for some questions lots
have come in
um I think you checked it up on your
page so lots of personal ones I think so
we'll see what we get from a few of
these ask him about his scat on his
forehead
I've never noticed a scar on your
forehead if it's what I know they're
talking about so at the end of um our NZ
20's campaign obviously I was coming off
the back of some dusty play
and uh it wasn't you know the best
result at the time for New Zealand under
20s and so again talking around you know
coping mechanisms I had at the time I
just wanted to go out and drink and
forget about it and blur it all out yeah
um
so
at the end of the tournament we went out
we
had had a massive time but I just didn't
know how to you know stop yeah just keep
going
um and it got to a point where they were
trying to the boys are trying to take me
home and I was just trying to be a hero
and just ran off I was like now I'm all
good sprinted off and went head first
into a pole and just ripped my head up
and so what one of the boys he's he says
to this day he thought I was dead
because of how limp I was
um
took me up and I was still trying to be
a hero we get back to the hotel and I'm
trying to run off and just be a pest and
I just like rock my head up against the
elevator door and I just
so I had this lump in my head I honestly
reckon it was for like nine months like
it didn't look like it was a bruise
necessarily but it was just like this
lump that was there for ages so I'm
pretty sure that's what I mean it sounds
about right that is a sloppy drunk yeah
yeah a sloppy kid at the time didn't
yeah and was that what you're like even
like through this whole journey when you
got when you did go down that downhill
spiral where where you're pretty sloppy
drunk like that
um I just now it didn't always look like
slop I just wasn't I just wasn't me yeah
you know I was
trying to make up for everything so much
by pretending to be someone else so I
was just very outgoing yeah that's
interesting okay next one worst bit of
advice your dad gave you
can't be much of that right yeah it was
my coach mate he's one of the greats
wasn't he
um
I'd say when he tells me to always aim
for the right sticks when you're kicking
because I never get it I think there's
more to do with me than there's them
okay uh you might have mentioned this
one before
um when you spoke about um delete those
footage but ask him about his famous
kick against Southland at Westpac
so there's another one of the dusty
comebacks that was on the year when I
was
when I was like a couple I think it was
maybe two weeks leading up to leaving
the environment oh yeah I asked him to
give my contract kind of taken away
um
I think we're lining up
uh on their 22
um so you know not not far out from The
Trial line
um boys are throwing all these different
calls at me and you know I'm just like
trying to just hold it all together
being on there and then Ben lamb passes
the message and he's on the right wing
yeah following these like cross kick
cross kick yeah and me just having no
confidence at whatsoever is like yeah
sweet
and then I just
I I'm I'm pretty sure it landed like 10
meters behind where it was just yeah at
the time that shattered me looking back
it's crack up yeah and you haven't
played since
that was the moment I decided to hang it
up
okay this one's from uh Legend pity
weepoo any Ambitions to have come back
in League or rugby
um
not to come back not not to try and
pursue any goals around that space I
would love to play uh with with my
brother and cousins for wainui rugby
league though oh yeah for probably
before they were able to
to well before they they can't play
anymore um because I probably got 10 15
years on them
um yeah that'd be something cool because
again I think I alluded to it before
like growing up on wino it was just it
was the greatest Community to be around
and all my family I I was privileged and
having all my family around me all the
time and so I had so many opportunities
to like I said before just go out and
Jam play Sunday touch with all of them
flag on the Wednesdays with them random
sevens tournaments throughout the whole
year in nines tournaments
um so being able to recreate those
moments that would be real cool probably
minus the highlight reels now
that on the wing now yeah
okay next one best bullet streak memory
oh I probably don't have any best Fuller
Street memories
[Music]
so yeah was that your flat when you were
injured yeah true that's very kind of
winter when yeah as I was talking about
yeah I was going out and about in just
yeah all right can't remember a thing
okay ask him about the Kendrick Lamar
trip I don't remember this one either no
no this one was this is actually really
cool because
um was depending on how you look at it
it might be horrible but so Peter manga
Jensen and I we were real Keen to go
down and watch Kendrick Lamar
um but I think it was down in Dunedin
with the hurricanes and it was like a
Wednesday night or something or two it
was a Tuesday night down in Dunedin
um during the middle of the campaign
um well your hand is talking about
whether or not we wanted to do it and
I'm pretty sure we talked to tjp and I
around it yeah as well and he was like
come on you know you guys are young go
for it um it's on you know the Wednesday
should be the rest day anyway
um so take the risk like you know yeah
in a way it felt like he gave out
blessing
um
and so here we went oh we went away but
in the week leading up the schedule
changed oh so the Wednesday was a
full-on here he is like D-Day and
everything and so we went down like had
him had a Mean Time
flew back at six a.m ready for I think
it was 8 30 and train team meeting and
training and those hard ass day
great memory
yeah
then didn't play out the way we expected
it to well at least you got your early
flight and you're back into it yeah yeah
sure sure all right that's good stuff
okay what piece of advice would you give
your younger self
has just be more Curious uh let's see
what you're interested in um I was I was
so determined from a young age of the
one pathway I wanted to go down I didn't
really look up and
look around and ask myself why
um why I'd be interested in other areas
um so that's probably yeah the biggest
thing I'd give to my younger self is
that there's so much more to life than
something that's still very clearly
passionate for you but there's you know
yeah there's so much more you can be
learning
um
talk before how it struggled with their
whole purpose and then going into the
physical side of things it was the same
thing like my purpose was fully derived
from sport growing up so if I could talk
to my younger self I would be around
just kind of reframing the way you you
look at life because even when I was
taking all the boxes of study healthy
healthy relationships
um you know taking care of my savings
those were all built on one pillar
around rugby where in reality it's
supposed to be side by side yeah so when
this one crumbled everything else
crumbled because of the way I I looked
at the world so that'd be yeah I could
talk to myself jeez
it's good advice for a young TJ uh okay
two more
um he does a great rendition of Toot It
and Boot It by yeah would love to hear
it
Betsy
is that a song I don't even know it yeah
it was a song that we all loved in the
boarding house oh that's right oh one of
my mates loved it I never liked it
[Music]
okay last one best piece of advice you
have for a woodland listener you gave
some to the younger self but now just
for the general Waterland listener out
there man
shoot uh
uh I would go to that Curiosity one but
I've used it so
um yeah just don't fit value of what
you're wanting to go through
um
going off the back of I want to explore
other areas in your life sometimes the
only way to find out what you want to do
is finding out what you don't want to do
so if you're more Curious in that space
and you accept that some things aren't
going to work out as long as you take
the lessons that you pull from it then
it isn't a waste of time yeah
you should embrace aspects of failure
rather than view it
best ever yes curiosity fear of failure
oh so good mate absolute pleasure having
you on the podcast
like as part of that Journey which I'm
just like man I'm so gutted that you had
to go through all of that
um never got to see you really where you
we probably belonged in the under the
big lights on a or on the TV on a Friday
Saturday night but awesome to hear how
you've gone through those struggles and
got to where you are and um in a really
good space so like awesome to hear you
open up and talk so honestly about that
I think so many guys will get so much
out of that especially anyone going
through an injury if if they're feeling
sorry for themselves going through uh
won him in injury I can I only have to
listen to this to feel I'm probably
grateful for not having to go through
what you did but um really appreciate
you coming on being so open and giving
up your time mate thanks bro honestly
awesome to be here I love that um
there's that the appetite for for people
to want to to hear and learn and listen
to
um their transition journey and the
adversity that comes with wanting to
pursue a life and and I'm high
performing Sports so appreciate
hey guys thanks for listening and if
you've got this far I'm guessing you
enjoyed the episode so if you did please
give it a share if you can and also
cheers to our mates at space we're
sponsoring this episode
[Music]
absolutely
[Applause]
[Music]